we've harnessed the power of artificial
intelligence to make life faster
and easier and as people are now using
ai on a daily basis
we're hearing more and more about the
future of work
as people delegate more tasks to
machines and software systems
they are becoming concerned about job
security
there's a lot of challenges associated
with artificial intelligence
one of the ones that's gotten the most
attention is
the idea that human workers are going to
be replaced
by computer workers but a changing
workforce
is something that society has dealt with
before
and contrary to what you might think
we're not really facing
mass automation in fact while
some jobs might disappear new ones are
emerging
one of the interesting examples is
people were really worried that the atm
was going to get rid of all of the
tellers
it turns out what happened is that the
invention of the atm
actually makes it much more economical
to open
many more bank branches which then have
employees associated with them
humans are really good at figuring out
ways to be useful when we look at the
future of work
it's not really about whether humans
will be replaced by
ai but rather how we can support workers
in an evolving job market
we need to consider the existing skills
we should invest in
and the new skills that might be needed
in the future we think
there will be new jobs created as usual
but it doesn't mean that people will be
able to
train themselves to these new jobs so
there's a lot of i think important
politics to be done there the future of
work is just one of many pressing issues
facing society
and governments around the world are
already looking for solutions
this is where policymakers come in to
look at how ai
is impacting our social economic and
political lives
[Music]
one of the biggest challenges that has
emerged in the context of ai
is privacy
there's a struggle between privacy and
performance and artificial intelligence
because the more information that ai has
on you the
more accurate decisions it can make i
don't think people should be worried
about algorithms
they should question though how the
algorithms
are used you know how sometimes it feels
like instagram is reading your mind
that's because an algorithm is
collecting your information and
making predictions about what you might
like
and there's plenty of information to
collect we
regularly provide our personal data all
the time
simply by interacting with ai
every time we click a headline like a
post or google something
we're offering data about our thoughts
interests or real-time locations
and since ai is developing at such a
rapid pace
our privacy laws are a little outdated
this means that companies are able to
collect analyze and share data
often without our knowledge and the way
our data is used
could influence our political leanings
and actions
people need to understand that their
data is very useful
to governments and companies if you're
on social media
and you're liking a lot of posts with a
particular political bent
you have to be aware that the social
media site will use that data
to manipulate what you're seeing to show
you news stories that
appeal to your political persuasion
as more and more of our data is being
grouped together
maybe ascend overseas we need to be
a lot more aware of where our data is
going and who's taking advantage of it
the issue of privacy raises broader
questions
around the impacts of ai not just when
it comes to data collection
but also how this data is analyzed
as we all know humans are far from
perfect
but these imperfections can often carry
over into our machines
this leads to another important
challenge facing researchers and
developers today
bias current systems are basically these
specialized little units that do exactly
one
thing and very well the problem is
that that thing is going to depend on
how we train them
and on the data that we provide for them
so we've seen examples of these ai
systems
developing problematic racial and
gender biases when i choose to gather
data
about a specific disease in a specific
population
i am embedding my positive or negative
biases in those choices
everything from when i ask questions to
what questions i
ask to what data i choose to record how
frequently i choose to record it
and about what kinds of conditions those
are all choices
that may cause certain conditions to be
over or under reported
or completely misunderstood if a data
set is skewed by human judgment
a real world bias can be perpetuated by
our systems
so we need to consider the data we're
collecting but also
how we build the system itself models
that are built
under certain assumptions will learn
certain relationships
more frequently or more efficiently one
popular model
uses text to learn relationships between
words
this kind of machine learning is how
gmail can give you suggestions as you
type
pretty handy right
they do astonishingly well at tasks like
word completion
they look like they're reasoning
intelligently about human relationships
but unfortunately we train these models
on human generated text that can mean
data from
the internet and so they'll learn
relationships like
man is to woman as king is to queen
as programmer is to housewife in a
clinical context
we've looked at note template completion
what that means is i give you the same
sentence right
42 year old blank patient
is experiencing dementia should be
discharged
to blank so there's two blanks there you
could change the gender
and see what happens to the outcome you
could change the ethnicity
and see what happens to the outcome and
what we've found is that there are stark
differences
in the symptoms that we predict in the
outcomes or interventions that get
recommended
if you just change ethnicity so
caucasian patients who
are found to be belligerent or
adversarial
it's recommended that they get sent for
example to
more care but belligerent
african-american patients
our model is assuming all of these
biases
and so the recommended word is prison
cases like this
show how bis data could end up
jeopardizing a person's safety in the
real world
and there's been a lot of talk about the
challenge of safety with ai
the idea that systems could potentially
cause harm to humans
the classic example of that is with
self-driving cars this situation that i
read about recently
the car crashed into someone because
that person walked out from behind a
mailbox
now the car in receiving the data that
normally receives
would never have had a situation of
having something walk out from behind a
mailbox all of a sudden
then when something walks out from
behind it for the first time ever
it doesn't react appropriately to be
clear self-driving cars are not
horribly dangerous the challenges that
we face are precisely getting them to
deal with these
unexpected situations researchers are
training them to better anticipate these
situations
but the issue of bias is connected to
another key challenge
ethics we depend on ai for lots of
things
from forecasting stock markets to
filtering emails
the challenge comes if we start relying
on machines to make decisions
without human oversight ethics refers to
the responsible use of ai
this means considering when and how ai
systems should make decisions
or if we should be using these systems
at all
ethics has been a big part of the
discussion around ideas like
self-driving cars
when do we rely on them to make choices
and what are the values guiding these
choices
for all the autonomous driving systems
people always come up with the questions
of but what is
what is the algorithm going to do if
they have a choice between
killing an old person or a baby
i mean what would you do like you would
have one second to decide
what would you do in many ways
we're still defining what we consider to
be ethical behavior for humans
in the context of a.i this raises some
important questions
if a self-driving car does take a human
life
whose fault is that or if a system is
reinforcing inequality
who's liable this is the challenge of
accountability in ai
determining who's held responsible when
systems make decisions that impact our
safety
property rights or freedoms
we need to be vigilant
about public policy about
big private companies having so much
power
i think definitely this should be
regulated and they should not be the one
making the decisions
about all these tools which has so much
impact on people's lives
i think it's hard to understand all of
the implications that your research
might have later on
but it's important to put yourself
through those processes
and be very explicit when you write up
work or when you release code
about all of the limitations that a work
has
this is why researchers are working
together with industry professionals
on something called explainability
mapping out how and why machines make
certain decisions
but of course humans can't always
explain our own behavior either
at the end of the day most of the time
people's decisions are actually
seemingly unexplainable there are
processes that happened in their brains
and we don't really know why
some of these issues like privacy or
safety
governments have been dealing with for a
long time but as we push forward with
innovation
policymakers will need to start looking
at these challenges through the lens of
ai
considering how we can make sure that
it's harnessed for the greater good
and in many cases this transformative
technology
could be what helps us improve ourselves
as humans
machine learning could actually help
people be better one of the things that
machine learning could be used for
is to investigate where biases exist and
highlight
that human behaviors need to change
before we trust them enough
to say that they are the gold standard
that we want to reproduce with machine
[Music]
learning
you